okay so we've talked about how Fox News
is normally the propaganda arm of the
Republican Party and carries water for
the Trump administration but that you
have these occasional voices of reason
Shepard Smith is one sometimes chris
wallace every once in a while Judge
Andrew Napolitano one time that I can
remember Neil Cavuto talked some sense
into the standard Republican talking
points and indeed Shep Smith
fact-checked Donald Trump's almost
completely lie riddled speech Tuesday
evening about the non-existent border
crisis and it's pretty delightful for
being Fox News now I will admit to you
normally it wouldn't be news that a
television channel fact-checked what a
politician said that that's not normally
something where we would say breaking
fact-checking was done by journalists
but because it's Fox News it is sort of
newsworthy this happened right between
Trump speech and the Pelosi Schumer
Democratic rebuttal a few minutes later
and it seems that if Trump's base was
convinced by the speech maybe hearing
the facts from Shep Smith might pull
them back in the other direction take a
look
President Trump speaking from the Oval
Office in a short time there will be a
response from the Democrats he made a
number of claims there speaking
specifically about a murder rates among
those who are undocumented immigrants
the government statistics show that
there is less violent crime by the
undocumented immigrant population than
by the general population he called it a
crisis of the heart and soul he talked
about drug crossings for the border but
government statistics show much of the
heroin actually comes not over the
unguarded border but through ports of
call he talked about undocumented
crossings over the past the past months
in fact the number of undocumented
crossings over the southern border has
been steadily down over the last ten
years and the government reports that
there is more outward traffic than
inward traffic as for the trade deal he
mentioned with Mexico which he said
would pay for the wall that trade deal
is not yet complete and the president
said that law enforcement professionals
have requested the five point seven
billion dollars it's he who requested it
and it's he who said he would own the
shut
nevertheless he's making the case to
keep his base together on this matter
Chris Wallace is live with us in
Washington does that make the case Chris
for his base well it certainly does make
the case for his base the question is
that whether the base is enough and the
answer is it isn't because the Democrats
in an election in which the border wall
was a major issue took control of the
house and they have enough votes in the
Senate also to block any legislation
there you know this is just the facts
right but when you hear it on fox news
it sounds heretical it sounds radical
because this is what the truth looks
like and it's not what you usually see
on fox news channel it's funny that fox
news fact-checking trump is noteworthy
but it is because they've been his
propaganda arm and i was actually
looking at some of the comments on this
segment and articles about it they are
filled with trumpets calling this
segment that i just played for you a hit
job okay think about that stating facts
which contradict the president is seen
as a hit job in some circles but when
it's Fox News it actually matters and is
important and we should applaud them and
thank them for it because I know that
it's not going to change what Fox is
that Shepard Smith every once in a while
tells the truth but you have to
understand that there's a huge group of
people who will reject anything they
hear anywhere other than Fox News period
so even though there are Fox News
viewers who think you can't trust Shep
because he comes up with this stuff
which we call the truth merely having
something like this on Fox News is
important because it actually has a much
better chance of breaking through the
echo chamber if Anderson Cooper does
exactly the same thing it's fine he
should be doing it it's not breaking
through to any trumpets who have been
primed to say that's fake news and
they're lying and we have the
alternative facts when Shep Smith does
it on Fox News primetime it actually
might get through to some of those
trumpets not all I mean you know many
people as I said already hate Shep Smith
and every time he says something that's
true they start saying homophobic things
about him but some frak
of the fox news audience Pat might see
this and say maybe I do need to
reconsider because even Fox News seems
to be telling me that the president
isn't being upfront here and he best
believe that the president is ticked off
about this generally Sean Hannity is on
during the nine o'clock slot but maybe
because of this special event the
presidential address they had Chris
Wallace there and of course Shep Smith I
don't know if the Trump team anticipated
that but it was bad calculation in in
that case because they probably would
have pushed it through a different time
when they had a more favorable Fox News
host on well not usually Fox just puts
on Shep and Chris Wallace I think no
matter when these things would have been
I think even at a different time they
still bring on the same team for these
special events one other talking point
that has been spreading is that the
Democrats aren't proposing anything to
stop the shutdown and move forward and
there are people who are falling for
clump Trump's claim about that and it
should be repeated widely that the House
already passed the bill to reopen
government it included one of the bills
included money for border security but
not for the border wall it would have
reopened government and given
Republicans almost everything that they
wanted on border security except for the
wall the Senate said no thanks Trump
would have vetoed it anyway from the
reports that we saw so it's a lie that
Democrats aren't coming to the table
that's one that Shepard Smith did not
fact check otherwise doing a good job I
mean he just told the truth he just told
the truth about what it is that Donald
Trump said Trump the great negotiator
doesn't seem to know how negotiations
are supposed to work and we'll talk more
about the latest attempt at those
negotiations after the break I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show one of
today's sponsors is privacy dot-com
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it you just take a
few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy coms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number
on the Internet and you use these
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online and with one click of a
button you have the ability to create
multiple virtual cards delete cards
freeze and unfreeze cards you can put a
limit on a card so a company won't be
able to charge you more than you
actually want them to and it protects
you from being hacked it protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program and it's perfect for signing up
for free trial somewhere if you don't
want your real credit card number to be
exposed and on file and their app and
browser extension let you autofill the
virtual credit card number into the
credit card field when you're buying
things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets 5 dollars towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link below